[Music]
do you know of a common belief that
many teachers have about having a
youtube channel
many teachers think that the only reason
why they should have a youtube channel
is so that they can upload their
pre-recorded videos to it and share it
with their students
but that's not true there are many other
things you could do with your youtube
channel
let's understand that in this video
[Music]
we all know that there is a wide variety
of great quality learning content
available on youtube
and as teachers we can use these videos
to teach our students using google
classroom
consider the situation where you want to
create your own collection of videos
about a particular topic for your
students what you need to create then
is a playlist it's nothing but a
collection of videos about one topic
now you could add your own videos to
your playlist or you could also add
videos created by
other creators to your playlist let's
focus on the latter here
how do we add other youtube videos to
our playlist
it's very easy we search for the video
first
once you pick a video you should watch
it to make sure it's a good quality
video
that is appropriate and relevant for
your students to watch
at the bottom right corner here you will
see the save button
clicking on it will show you this screen
you can then
create a new playlist by clicking here
and then providing a proper name to the
playlist
just like this name you could have a
playlist name like
8a math linear equations this playlist
will contain
all the videos you curated for this
particular chapter
you can either keep your playlist public
unlisted or private
if it's public it means anybody on
youtube will be able to see your
playlist
if it's unlisted it means only the
people with your playlist link will be
able to see it
and if it's private it means only a few
people you have shared it with will be
able to see your playlist
the second and the third options come in
handy when you want
only your students to watch the videos
in your playlist
let's keep the playlist public for now
now if you want to add a second video to
your playlist then you pick your second
video
click on save select the playlist
and it's done you can see your playlist
on the left here
and you can always edit or delete your
playlist whenever you feel like
you can also change the name or shuffle
the order of videos
or even add a description for your
playlist when you go back to your
channel page by clicking here
you will see your playlist stored under
the playlist tab here
but if it was unlisted or private you
wouldn't see it here
how can i share this playlist with
someone else now
one simple way is by using the right
click option here
and clicking on copy link address to
test the link you could just open a new
tab
and paste the link in the address bar
once this link is pasted in the address
bar the first video will start playing
and you will see the list of other
videos in a sequence on the right
after the first video ends youtube will
automatically start playing the second
one
what else could these curated playlists
help you with
after you conduct a class or a live
session you could share your playlist
link with your students
now that playlist could cover topics
that you have taught in your class
or the topics that you're going to teach
in your upcoming class
with access to videos about the material
you teach your students will be able to
review topics at their own pace
and will also be able to bring their
doubts and comments to class
all of this will immensely improve the
learning outcomes for your students
but before you start curating videos for
your students
there's an important thing you need to
know about searching for videos
what do most of us do when we want to
search for a video of a particular topic
well we enter the title in the search
bar look at the list of videos that
appear here
and select one of them right have you
ever noticed this filter button
it can help you filter your search based
on the parameters you want
let's think of a few examples what if
you didn't want to watch the videos that
were uploaded many years ago
what if you just wanted to watch the
videos that were recently uploaded
in the last 12 months in order to do
that you just have to click on this year
and all the videos you see would have
been uploaded in the last 12 months
so you can select the latest videos
which will most probably have the latest
information for your students
sometimes you may want to share an
entire playlist of videos created by
others with your students with your
fellow teachers
or maybe even your friends then you just
have to click on playlist
and you will get access to all the
playlists that your creators have
created
this playlist has 9 videos this one has
19 videos and so on
you can just do a right click here copy
the link
and share it with whoever you like okay
what else
if you wish to watch short bite-sized
videos
you can click on this button here and
all the videos you see will be less than
four minutes in length
what if you want to see the videos which
have many views
then you click on filter and then sort
by views
and you will see the list of videos
sorted by the number of views
so the filter button helps you filter
the videos that you're looking for
okay what else as content consumers we
always have preferences
you may like the content delivered by a
few certain channels
and youtube gives you this option to
subscribe to those channels
once you subscribe to your favorite
channels whenever they upload videos
you will be notified of them and that
helps you stay updated
all you need to do is search for the
channel you like
and click on the subscribe button here
and then click on the bell icon to make
sure you receive the notifications
this isn't the only way though say you
search for a video and while watching it
if you end up loving the content then
you can also click on the subscribe
button you see here
so these were a couple of ways to
subscribe to your favorite channels on
youtube
going back to your channel will show you
the list of channels you have subscribed
to
in the channels tab here it may take
some time for them to appear here
alternatively you can also see your
subscriptions here on the left side of
the screen
every time these channels upload videos
or share a post you will be notified if
you have clicked on the bell icon
these are some of the things you can do
with your youtube channel apart from
uploading videos to it
in the next video i will give you tips
on how you can shoot videos at home
without really investing any money
see you there